house oversight subcommittee held an
emergency hearing this afternoon titled
a caravan of illegal immigrants a test
of u.s. borders so why was that
necessary
well why because there are new reports
that ms-13 members are posing as minors
traveling with the migrant Caravan
lovely as if that weren't enough this
week in the Jacksonville Florida area a
twice deported illegal immigrant from El
Salvador was charged with manslaughter
over the 2016 death of the officer
trying to track him down
deputy Eric Oliver was a Navy veteran
and described as a hero in his community
he was 32 years old and his daughter was
6 when he died joining me now is
Republican congressman Ron De Santis who
chaired today's hearing he's also
running for governor of Florida I
endorsed you so long ago it's not even
funny and let's talk about the caravan
crime and our open border congressman
good to see you hey how are you great
this was wild because we see reports of
large numbers of people forget the
caravan crossing the border all together
at one time then they're just taken into
custody and then like who are you who
are you that's one guys like well I'm
being recruited for ms-13 and Los
Angeles it's wild it's another we need
this wall not funded in the Omnibus we
need the wall and I think you know the
the consensus amongst most of the
witnesses today was one Trump order the
catch-and-release to be done but yet
they're still that's what I'm saying
they're still doing it know doing it and
then the other thing is is when you have
the massive border surges that really is
a godsend to the drug cartels and the
amount of fentanyl and all this junk
that they've been able to bring into our
country that has caused a lot of people
to lose their lives and so we've got to
get this under control and what does it
mean without a wall we go to I keep
going back to the wall it's not that
it's not everything but it's a big
deterrent and walls do not have
prosecutorial discretion so if a
bureaucrat doesn't want to enforce the
law if they want to do the old Obama
policies or if you have an
administration like Obama where they
basically just give up on and
or spent then you don't have the your
laws being enforced but the wall the
walls the wall and the places where they
have it like San Diego it works now I
want to read this to people so they
understand the numbers were talking
about again agents assigned to the Yuma
station in Arizona came upon a large
group of 61 illegal immigrants who
crossed the border Monday afternoon this
from Breitbart near the san luis port of
entry in southern Arizona
the illegal border crossers consisted of
a single Mexican national and 59
Guatemalans in one Salvadoran who
claimed to be an unaccompanied minor
according to the information that they
received then they questioned them it
turned out as I said that that one
supposed an unaccompanied minor was an
adult who was an ms-13 recruit from the
LA ms-13 now do you know when they come
in then what happens to them because
we've gotten rid of a lot of the
detention centers didn't we along the
border so what then what happens well it
depends on what they say I mean you know
there's we have asylum laws that people
know what to say to claim asylum now in
almost every instance it's pretty
obvious when they're coming from my
Guatemala that that they're not
necessarily qualifying but I mean Asylum
is like you're being persecuted because
of race religion political opinion just
life and Guatemala know persecuted right
I mean those countries have problems but
that's not enough but what happens is
once they do that they get a trial in
like two years well guess what they get
released into our country they're
usually not know what you're saying
tonight is despite what the what the
administration has said catch and
release is still happening it is still
happening against the wishes of the
elected president and and that's the
problem mean if you have a caravan
coming they should just be stopped at
the border interest should not be
allowed to cross the border people
watching the show now are like why is
this happening it is infuriating they
know they can do it and by the way the
Yuma sector in Arizona is reporting that
they're seeing a surge in larger groups
so now they're not doing the trickle
trickle through they're doing large
groups moving on mas across the border
and you know you use the word invasion
people say oh that's so mean what else
do you call this in the large groups you
have the human trafficking
the drug I mean it really is a boon for
the cartel there's an ad that's being
run about you that makes you look like
you know a combination of you know of
dr. Jekyll Frankenstein and you know a
terrorist will just see it in the
background oh we can play it okay let's
let's watch it the president this is the
same Ron DeSantis who voted to get Ron
DeSantis says he wants to help President
Trump drain the swamp but when a
reporter asked to Santos at precedent
Trump was mentally stable he refused to
answer or defend the president this is
the same Ron DeSantis who voted to give
food stamps to illegal immigrants hardly
part of the president's make America
great again agenda Ron de santis can we
trust this swamp creature to leave
Florida hardly part of the president's
plan the vote oh it's so ridiculous so
that Adam Putnam did that well I think
its supporters so this is like you've
been one of the most stalwart supporters
of this president on almost every issue
that I can think of just why months ago
I endorsed you and how do people even
get away with saying that like so
actually so they're running on radio
we've some of the radio stations have
had to take it down already because it's
false you know when they say voting for
food set and then they cite a bill where
I voted against the farm bill that had
Obama's food stamp policies in there so
I voted against all the food stamps
certainly wouldn't do it for people here
illegally so it's a hundred percent
false radio stations have taken it down
we're working with the TV stations it's
just absurd how does a race looking in
Florida I mean Scott was you know he was
a force in Florida now you know rick
Scott's moving on to the fact that
they're running ads against me you know
dogs don't bark at parked car so I'm on
the move they see that that rattles a
lot of people so I'd say we're doing
what we need to be doing all right well
I want you to continue to educate the
people on what's happening at the border
because I think Americans when they hear
that catch and release is still
happening are infuriated and shocked and
the president needs to step up and take
take take the members of Congress or
allowing this to happen to task Ron de
santis thank you so much